[Musik]
Köln ist eine Metropole hier leben über
eine Million Menschen 6% gelten als
reich 23 Prozent sind arm 23 Prozent das
sind über 200.000 Menschen die monatlich
weniger als 1000 Euro zum Leben haben
oder auch gar nichts Armut hat viele
Gesichter sie sichtbar oder versteckt
sich hinter bürgerlichen Fassaden die
hier in Köln-Mülheim
seit zwei Jahren angefangen und die
haben auch seit zwei Jahren keine
Heizung
und in Treppenhaus keine Strom
seit ungefähr zwei drei Monaten bezahlt
sie keine Miete
sie ist auch damit nicht einverstanden
da der Eigentümer leider sich nicht
kümmert also ich kenne viele
Katastrophen also das haut mir den Boden
unter den Füßen weg das sind absolute
unmenschliche unwürdige Zustände
Schimmel überall keinen Strom und eine
kleine Heizung mit Strom heizen müssen
das ungekosten verursacht ähm
der Mietpreis für für absolute also mir
ist ganz klar das darf nicht sein dass
Menschen unwürdig das heißt wenn wir
unsere Grundgesetz ernst nehmen brauchen
wir neue Gesetze und ein neues Gesetz
müssen wenn ein Vermieter ist ein Haus
in solch einem Zustand vorkommen lässt
und sich nicht kümmert und das schwarze
Schimmel ist Gesundheitsschädigung
absolut ne das heißt der müsste muss
dann enteignet werden wir brauchen neue
Gesetze im Umgang mit mit Vermietern die
eigentlich nicht mehr viel los sind die
eigentlich Verbrechen sind so ein
Verbrecher ist jemand der kriminell mit
anderen umgeht nämlich die Würde des
Menschen beachtet ihre Gesundheit
schädigt warum gibt es das aber und da
wohnen sechs bis acht Familien mit
mehreren Personen wer guckt da weg
gute Frage alle alle eine ganze
Gesellschaft guckt da weg
in Rentner den der Wohnung friert die
Mutter die die würde verliert das Kind
ist sich in der Schule schämt der Vater
der sich zu Tode Grenz
[Musik]
Hans mörter schaut hin der Pastor der
Lutherkirche in der Kölner Südstadt ist
seit 40 Jahren das soziale Gewissen der
Stadt er setzt sich für arme Obdachlose
und Alleinerziehende ein auch der Kampf
gegen Kinderarmut liegt mochte am Herzen
20 jedes fünfte Kind in Deutschland lebt
in Armut wie kann das sein
kinderarmut ist in der Regel die Armut
für die von Eltern bzw hauptsächlich von
alleine ziehenden Müttern weil weil sie
eben den Job nicht haben weil sie z.B
auch kein abgebrochene Ausbildung haben
der Typ ist wieder im Stich gelassen hat
alle mich Versprechung gemacht hat dann
nur die Ausbildung da nicht die Frauen
die Ausbildung nicht zu Ende gemacht und
dann in dieser Spirale stecken da nicht
mehr rauskommen
Tanja und Ramona sind alleinerziehend
sie leben mit ihren Kindern von Hartz 4
einen Job haben sie nicht denn je kleine
die Kinder desto schwierige ist es für
Mütter Geld zu verdienen
finanziell oder sowohl als auch
ja wie geht es mir
finanziell nicht so besonders da haben
wir hier viele
kleine Problemchen sag ich jetzt mal
weil ich als alleinerziehende Mutter
komme mit dem Bürgergeld
vorher wie auch jetzt bin ich nicht
damit zurecht gekommen weil Kinder sind
teuer wie man weiß
meine Tochter ist jetzt im Moment in
einem Wachstumsschub wieder und ich
verzichte auf alles was geht eigentlich
wollte nur was ich habe ist mein Makel
das das einzige was ich mir gönnen diese
Wohnung wird vom sozial wird vom
Jobcenter übernommen
wie viel Geld haben sie zur Verfügung
ich bekomme vom Jobcenter 5
6 so um den Dreh
davon geht dann auch erstmal der Teil
weg die Strom dann Lebensmittel gehe ich
dann Nötigste holen nur an einen
Pflegemitteln das was mein Kind jetzt
braucht die Kühlschrank erstmal voll
machen damit ich zu essen hat dann
Katzen sind auch teuer
ja und dann Leben tue ich eigentlich nur
vom Kindergeld der Rest ist alles weg
durch das Bürgergeld haben sie jetzt 50
Euro mehr bekommen
ist ein Witz 50 Euro haben Sie schon mal
die Preise geguckt im Ende Supermärkte
oder Drogeriemarkt überall wie geht's
ihnen denn sie haben ja zwei Kinder sind
auch alleinerziehend genauso wie bei
Tanja ne wir machen halt unsere Touren
vormittags weil ich kein obs Platz habe
für meine Tochter ich muss jetzt schon
wieder um 11:45 Uhr holen also
arbeitsmäßig lohnt das auch nicht weil
bist du da bist und wieder zurück muss
sein Kind Schüler holen
klappt auch nicht jetzt im größerem
Bruder sagen ne hier hör mal nimm deine
Schwester holt die ab
zu viel Verantwortung sag ja
hauptsächlich kriegen auch nur meine
Kinder ich war mir das letzte mal was
geholtten
will oder vom Sperrmüll ne fühlen sich
den Armen doch in dem Sinne ja Armen
sind wir in dem Sinne finanzieren ne
aber reich an dem was man haben wir
machen aus NICHTS machen was besser
draußen also versuchen zumindest ne so
weit geht
kriegen sie das denn zu spüren von von
Leuten Nachbarn bekannten und das ist
eigentlich egal jeder weiß dass wir mal
Müll gucken aber was eigentlich peinlich
ist ne aber im Endeffekt
Leute
ist doch ja nein
also sie kennen sie schon ja schon ja
ich weiß auch nicht warum aber ich habe
anfangs habe ich mich auch geschehen ne
also in Sperrmüll zu fühlen oder
Mülltonnen rein zu gucken ne aber wenn
ich sehe was die Leute wegschmeißen ne
wo das Geld hingeht
sie haben jetzt viele Möbel und das
sieht ja hier sehr schick aus machen Sie
also aus nichts viel genau genau das
sind hauptsächlich alles Sachen die ich
auf dem Sperrmüll finde
Einzelteile hier die Beine die habe ich
zum Beispiel von einem kaputten Tisch
abgemacht
und diese Platte gefunden und die dann
nur da dran verarbeitet die Musik ja ist
jetzt meine Theke ja
die Stühle habe ich vorgestern hier auf
dem Sperma gefunden die habe ich
gerettet ist auch nichts dran warum
schmeißen die Leute so weit weg
Tanja musste ihren Job als
Landschaftsgärtnerin aufgeben weil sie
krank wurde Ramona findet keinen weil
die Arbeitszeiten in der Regel nicht mit
den Betreuungszeiten abgestimmt sind
Pfarrer mörter kennt die beiden Frauen
und ihre ständigen Geld sorgen die
staatlichen Hilfen gehen für ihn nicht
weit genug auch nicht das neue
Bürgergeld
BürgerInnen Geld ist eine Idee jetzt
gewesen und das ist natürlich
gescheitert dann Widerspruch der FDP da
kann ich nicht immer leider nichts
anderes sagen und ich finde das finde
das schon fatal diese Fremdheit
gegenüber Menschen in der Notsituation
und diese Arroganz darüber hinwegzusehen
und zu denken man kann mit so ein
bisschen mit 50 lächerlichen in Euro ich
könnte nicht ich sag dann einfach mal
ich muss nach oben so so das reicht
nicht und der Einsatz war ja bei Grün
oder es wird ja auch eine andere und
auch der hat jetzt nicht gereicht aber
auf jeden Fall muss es mehr Geld sein es
ist so ist es eine Phase zu tun was aber
wir tun nicht wirklich was weil wir gar
nicht um die Situation der Menschen
wissen was müssen die tun was wäre die
Lösung wenn Bürgergeld nicht
funktioniert
also eine Lösung wäre auf jeden Fall ein
Grundeinkommen bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen dass das Basis anzusetzen
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen
Kindergrundsicherung das alles ist
Zukunftsmusik um den Bedürftigen jetzt
zu helfen gibt es in Köln seit zwei
Jahren ein Zentrum für allein dieses
Angebot hat eine große Nachfrage über
600 alleinerziehende Eltern haben hier
Rat gesucht und auch gefunden wir sind
keine Jobbörse aber wir unterstützen
unsere Klienten natürlich sehr gerne
dabei berufliche Neuorientierung zu
machen wir schauen eben wo sind die
Potenziale von unseren Klienten und
Klienten und natürlich gucken wir dann
auch wie können wir den Klient
unterstützen
gut in den Arbeitsmarkt eben reinzugehen
heißt wir können dann eben schauen dass
wir gute Bewerbungsunterlagen zum
Beispiel mit dem Klienten arbeiten dass
wir das Bewerbungsgespräch gut ja
sozusagen vorbereiten auf mögliche
Fragen schon uns mögliche Antworten
überlegen und da eben natürlich auch ja
unseren Klienten fit machen
Selbstbewusstsein stärken es scheint
sich keiner zu uns zu kommen wir merken
allerdings natürlich dass es eine für
den ein oder anderen Teilnehmer
Teilnehmerin eine gewisse Hürde gibt
hier erstmal hinzukommen ja viele sagen
uns dann ja ich bin schon mehrfach bei
euch vorbei gelaufen aber ich habe mich
nicht so richtig getraut aber dann habe
ich doch den Mut gefasst irgendwie zu
euch zu kommen ist sehr wichtig dass
eben bei uns im Schaufenster nicht steht
dass wir ein Zentrum sind wo man
irgendwie ja extra hinkommen kann um
Unterstützung zu bekommen um Hilfen zu
bekommen um staatliche Leistungen zu
bekommen sondern dass wir einfach ein
Zentrum für Alleinerziehende sind
[Musik]
viele Gesichter
der in der
[Musik]
Wohnung schämt der Vater der sich zu
Tode Grenz
Arm oder viele Gesichter nur eines nicht
Hans mörter unterwegs zu seinem
Herzensprojekt dem fringstreff den er
vor 20 Jahren mit aus der Taufe gehoben
hat
ein Café für alle und gleichzeitig auch
ein Beratungszentrum für Menschen die am
Rande der Gesellschaft leben
ich komme sozusagen schon über 20 25
Jahre hier
ich bin einer mit der ältesten die die
überhaupt hierher kommen ja und ich
finde die ganz toll ne also für Sie das
Besondere hier an dem Ort ja erstmal er
gibt ein schönes Essen und so weiter und
man unterhält sich die Kommunikation mit
den Leuten und sowas das ist soziale
Umfeld was man braucht um auch ein
bisschen
vernünftig leben zu können wenn man
unterhält sich und so weiter vielleicht
sich aus und so und ja was immer mehr ne
das ist eben das wichtigste was man hier
machen kann aber mehrere sein ja klar
kommt doch die ein oder andere
Freundschaft dann noch dazu ja das
gibt's
nette Leute kennen und so ne dann freut
man sich auch wieder wenn man am
nächsten Tag wieder damit und sich damit
hält und so und dann wird man quasi auch
wenn man gar nicht essen geht ne man
wird einfach dahin gezogen um sich auch
zu unterhalten und zu kommen zu
kommunizieren und so das ganz wichtig ja
40 45 Jahren hier wieder geht nein ja
wir sind ja dann auch mittlerweile etwas
älter geworden
385 Rente
385 oder dazu
wirklich mein Leben lang gearbeitet in
diesem Land hat mein Job gemacht ich war
zuverlässig ich bräuchte
640 € im Monat
640 Euro im Monat
ich würde sagen natürlich
dieses Gesetz
dann bezahlt die Kommune hat eine
Wohnung ja und wenn du jetzt wieder mehr
Rente kriegst dann kannst du
ja wieder abgehalten was sie mehr hast
für die Wohnung und dann hast du ja
wieder genauso viel wie zum Beispiel
Schwanz das müssen wir das bisschen
ausgeschlossen sein
miteinander
hat sich denn das Publikum geändert
ja es hat sich verändert also ist
vielfältiger geworden früher waren es
halt so die klassischen Obdachlosen
mittlerweile sind viele Frauen auch
dabei es gibt auch viele Menschen die
psychische Auffälligkeiten haben also
die im Bereich der Wohnungslosen
Obdachlosenhilfe das ist ein
Sammelbecken für ganz ganz viele die so
rausfallen aus allen möglichen Systemen
ich erlebe hier wurde indem ich gefragt
werde was ich kann auswählen es gibt
zwei verschiedene Essen zu Auswahl
vegetarisch und irgendwie Fleisch z.B
oder verschiedene Kuchen und so weiter
oder nee Kaffee und Getränke und da gibt
es eine Speisekarte lesen
kann mit dem Kellner kommunizieren ich
werde ernst genommen ich bin wichtig
hier ich bin kein Bittsteller also wie
bei der Tafel z.B da gehen die Leute hin
finde das sehr entwürdigend zum Teil und
müssen dahin gehen und sagen ich bin arm
müssen sich ausweisen und kriegen dann
was geschenkt aber keiner in so einer
Lebenssituation kann das einfach gut
annehmen weil das ist wirklich hat was
mit Würdelosigkeit zu tun und dadurch
dass wir hier so einen kleinen Obolus
verlangen für das Essen haben die
Menschen das Gefühl ja ich bekomme was
aber ich bezahle auch dafür also
Forderungen gehen immer an die Politik
aber kann die Gesellschaft wir auch was
tun ganz viel weil sie damit auch wieder
Politik beeinflussen das heißt Arbeiten
an den Klischees und verurteilen
Obdachlose sind Menschen und nicht
automatisch betrunkene permanent
betrunkene das ist aber das kriegt hier
in den Köpfen viele viele Menschen das
ist falsch
[Musik]
solche Bilder gehören inzwischen zum
Alltag in deutschen Großstädten in Köln
sind aktuell über 6000 Menschen
wohnungslos das heißt ohne Wohnung ohne
Arbeit ohne Krankenversicherung
[Musik]
in diesem Containern gibt es eine
Arztpraxis hier werden sozial
benachteiligte Menschen unentgeltlich
behandelt die Mediziner arbeiten
ehrenamtlich ein niederschwelliges
Angebot wer kommt wird versorgt von
Ärzten und Krankenschwestern meine
Aufgabe ist irgendwie eher so die
Wundversorgung irgendwie hier also viele
Menschen auf der Straße haben Probleme
mit tiefen Wunden an den Beinen offene
Beine genau das ist irgendwie so ein
bisschen Schwerpunkt irgendwie von mir
auch
das seelsorgerische ist irgendwie auch
nicht mehr Unterstützung von der Politik
wäre einfach auch nett ne
Aufmerksamkeit Unterstützung guckt hin
genau Platzierung oder einfach auch so
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit sich das
vielleicht auch mal hier auf den
Standort irgendwie hier könnt ihr
dauerhaft bleiben weil das ist ja jetzt
auch nur vorübergehend hier genau und
wenn da so in die Richtung mal was käme
man kriegt sehr viel zurück
eben dieses ne dieses unmittelbar
unverfälschte genau ja ich bin seit
jetzt zwei Jahren im Ruhestand und seit
ich das mache geht es mir wieder besser
herrlich niederschwellig auch helfen ne
das ist ja die Leute brauchen wirklich
die Hilfe und das möchte kaum jemand
machen also viele haben einfach die
berührungsakt weil die schmutzig sind
und ne oder auch nicht irgendwie
angenehm riechen aber
die brauchen aber trotzdem eine Umarmung
und auch mal irgendwie ein herzliches
Lächeln und ich denke das kann ich
einfach gut geben
bezahlbare Wohnraum in Deutschland ist
Mangelware als Obdachlose ist es deshalb
sehr schwer bis unmöglich eine Wohnung
zu finden in Finnland ist man schon
weiter durch das Projekt housing first
wurde dort die Obdachlosigkeit halbiert
hinter diesem hilfsansatz für Obdachlose
verbirgt sich die Vermittlung einer
Wohnung ohne Vorbedingungen der Pfarrer
aus der Kölner Südstadt ist auch hier
aktives ist einfach die Idee dass jeder
Mensch ein Recht auf Wohnung hat und
sich das nicht verdienen muss das heißt
in den normalen System müssen die Leute
sich irgendwie bewähren und irgendwann
kommen sie dann vielleicht in die
Vermittlung einer eigenen Wohnung bei
uns heißt es du bekommst zuerst die
Wohnung und dann stabilisierst du dich
guckst du sortierst dein Leben und
kriegst aber auch Begleitung nur so
lange es nötig ist dass die Begleitung
dazu da um sich auch irgendwann
rauszuziehen und das passiert 19
Wohnungen vermittelt vermietet mit
Mietvertrag und Unterschrift das ist das
entscheidende also in die
Selbstständigkeit rein 19 Wohnungen in
einer Millionenstadt Köln in Finnland
hat man mit diesem Prinzip die
Obdachlosigkeit halbiert warum
funktioniert das bei uns nicht
einfacher
wir wollten es und wir haben es gemacht
in Köln in Deutschland dass wir wollen
das schon riesenprozess und wenn dann
die Entscheidung gefallen ist in den
Stadträten wir wollen essen immer dann
als wir machen was denn
und dann
zieht und zieht und zieht es sich und
deswegen gehören die Promotoren dazu die
einfach sein wir geben hier Gas und das
tun wir eben auch und wir produzieren
Beispiele um zu zeigen der Politik zu
zeigen
ah es funktioniert und zwar erfolgreich
B der soziale klarspart unglaublich viel
Geld das heißt die Wohnung ist quasi
der Staat um auch die anderen Probleme
zu beheben ja in dem Augenblick wo ich
ein sicheres zu Hause habe
gestern sagen okay was ist nächstes dran
aber wie ich durch und für ihn Somat
haben
habe ich ja gar keine Orientierung weil
ich kein Zuhause habe weil ich keine
Basis habe
das berühmte Sofa mein eigenes Sofa also
mein eigenes Klo mein geschützten Raum
und wenn ich wenn ich in Nest habe dann
kann ich auch anders arbeiten also
losgehen für mein Leben sortieren mit
Hilfe wie viel Abbrüche gibt es bei
diesem Mietverträgen wo die Leute sagen
es gibt ja aber es gibt doch diese
berühmte diesen Freiheitsdrang eine
Wohnung hängt nicht aus ich liebe doch
das ist dran der berühmte weißreiniger
aufdachlosen ähm das ist eine Wohnung
einhängt ist ein Märchen der bürgerliche
Gesellschaft um sich ein gutes Gewissen
zu machen die wollen das ja so deswegen
lassen wir in Ruhe und tun gar nicht so
hat man Jahrzehnte lang gehandelt oder
nicht gehandelt das ist eine billige
faule gelogen Ausrede diejenigen die
meinen dass das so schön ist die
Freiheit zu genießen draußen so dass man
nur einen Tag oder zwei
Nächte im Frühjahr oder im Herbst oder
im Winter machen garantiere miteinander
reden
so wie ihr seht das ist mein kleiner
Flur
da geht's einmal ins Badezimmer und hier
ist meine Stube
Michael Hubert ist einer der 19 Menschen
die in Köln durch das hausing
first-projekt nicht mehr auf der Straße
wohnen müssen eine eigene
Wohnung Jahren wohnungslos wie ist das
so ja du kommst rein macht die Tür auf
bis in deinen eigenen vier Wänden es ist
warm du hast du hast eine Dusche du hast
eine Küche es ist wieder ein
selbstbestimmtes Leben der große
Unterschied ist ganz einfach dass ich
mich hier sicher fühle in diesen ganzen
Obdachlosenheim etc pp was ist so in
Deutschland gibt bist du einfach nicht
richtig sicher da wirst du eingezwängt
in irgendwelche kleinen Wohnungen die
sind vielleicht aber Zimmer in diesen
zehn bis 15 m² groß hat eine
Gemeinschaftsdusche und das war's hast
Schranken Spiegel in jedem Knast bist du
besser aufgezogen aufgezogen
bedeutet ja auch einen eigenen
Mietvertrag und ein Mietvertrag ist ja
irgendwo Eigenverantwortung
da freue ich ihn die ganze Sache
reingerutscht bin war ich ja auch
eigenverantwortlich ist hat ja alles neu
in deine Geschichte und es muss ja nicht
immer heißen dass jemand alkoholabhängig
oder drogenabhängig oder sowas war ich
bin halt durch einen schweren
Schicksalsschlag bin ich bin ich da
reingerutscht und dann geht eben diese
Spirale immer weiter nach unten wenn man
nicht aufpasst wie schwierig ist es in
deiner Lebenssituation eine eigene
Wohnung aus eigener Kraft zu finden sehr
schwer
erstens mal es gibt kein vernünftigen
Wohnraum und die Mieten sind einfach
exorbitant teuer fühlst du dich an
ich habe was im Kopf ich habe mein
ganzes Leben lang was gemacht ich
bestreite jetzt mein Leben wieder auf
neuen Wegen also ich bin nicht da und du
schämst dich auch nicht jetzt hier in zu
wohnen quasi in einer Wohnung die andere
für dich bezahlen nö warum ich habe mein
ganzes Leben lang bevor ich
zusammengebrochen bin habe ich Steuern
gelacht gezahlt viel viel Steuern
gezahlt
und es ist immer immer gerade so ich
kann es annehmen ich muss mich dafür
nicht schämen dafür ist sowas ja auch
gedacht warum soll ich jetzt den Kopf in
Sand packen und dass ich irgendwann vom
Jobcenter wieder weg will ist ganz klar
und das hat eben halt schon ganz viel
gebracht durch die Wohnung Dankern Haus
in först und jetzt geht's weiter
[Musik]
sich in der Schule schämt der Vater der
sich zu Tode Grenzen
nur eines nicht
und das Gesicht
sie sind geistlicher aber mischen sich
ziemlich in die Politik ein wird es gern
gesehen also als Pfarrer heißt es ja die
beten aber das was nützen wir ich bete
jetzt für die Armen allein gelassenen
oder oh Gott oh sicher was denn ich habe
schon lange glaube ich schon lange nicht
mehr an den Mann mit dem dicken Bart der
wunderbar gesehen der Macht nicht das
ist noch nicht einmal nette Spiele
sondern wir sind die gefragt hatten und
es geht spirituell geht's um eine
Energie die wir haben mit die erlebe ich
bei mir jedenfalls mit dieser Energie
kann ich Gesellschaft transformieren ich
kann Impulse gehen ich kann kämpfen ich
habe eine ungeheure Kraft und ziehe
andere mit mir und ich hoffe dass es
immer mehr wird dass wir wirklich in der
gesellschaftlichen Veränderungen kommen
nämlich basierend darauf Menschen ernst
zu nehmen und nicht Urteile sie zur
Übersicht zu haben sind Schubladen zu
stecken und in Zukunft zu versauen sie
ging gar nicht zu ermöglichen aus dem
Hamsterrad der rauskommt
egal wann und wo Pastor mörter unterwegs
ist kämpft er für die Menschen am
unteren Rand der Gesellschaft wie hier
bei einem rheinischen karnevalsbrauch
der nubbelverbrennung der nobel ist eine
Strohpuppe die in der Nacht zu
Aschermittwoch symbolisch für die Sünden
der Menschen büßen muss und verbrannt
wird
[Musik]
in Köln
8000 Wohnungslose 3000 auf der Straße
das hat nichts aber auch wirklich nichts
mit Freiheit und Romantik zu tun wie die
Oberbürgermeisterin ist glaubten
[Musik]
Obdachlose sind Menschen und sie haben
ein Recht auf würde und sie haben ein
Recht auf ihren eigenen Körper
[Musik]
[Applaus]
alleinerziehende Mütter sind Heldinnen
allein gelassen am Existenzgrund kämpfen
sie und sie wissen was Hunger ist mitten
in dieser Stadt auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
gibt es keine Jobs mit flexiblen
Arbeitszeiten und keine
Ausbildungsprogramme für Sie jedes
fünfte Kind in Deutschland ist von Armut
betroffen Klavierunterricht
ausgeschlossen Kino Popcorn als keine
Chance wird Zeit für eine Kinder
größer auch
[Applaus]
für dich
nicht
denn wir sind alle alle Menschen
[Musik]
denn wir sind
und in jedem
Menschen
[Musik]
und jeder ist Kölsche Jung